(ethereal chime plays)
- As we try to figure out what Ukraine is,
we're also trying to figure out
what the countries around Ukraine are.
And so over the course of this semester,
you'll have occasion to
think about what Russia is.
That's not our main subject, but I assume
it's come to mind already that Russia
is also not simple, and
that the history of Russia
is also not straightforward.
And that indeed this
war that's going on now
may have more to do with
uncertainty about what Russia is
than it does with uncertainty
about what Ukraine is.
Just something to think about.
Professor Bushkovitch,
our outstanding historian
of early modern Russia,
was going to lecture
on the formation of the
Russian state on Tuesday,
but he can't.
So I'm gonna do it instead.
The lecture is going to happen.
You're going to see, in this lecture,
that something like the
beginning of a Russian state
will start to appear.
And I want you to track that,
because the chronology of
all this is very important.
This is partly on my mind
because of where we are,
in fact, where we are in
the war, which is that,
as I'm sure most of you know,
the Russian Federation
has begun a mobilization
under the heading partial mobilization,
whatever that might mean.
But the edict in question
essentially allows
any Russian male to be mobilized for war.
And now people in Russia
are being mobilized for war
all over the country, but
notably, and not surprisingly,
in Asian Russia and in Southern Russia,
in places where people are poor,
or also in places where
people are ethnically,
as we say today, not Russian.
Which is a reminder that one
of the things that Russia is,
is an Asian state.
Most of the territory of Russia
is in fact in Asia, right?
And so, when Russia invaded Ukraine,
many of the soldiers who were invaded,
many of the casualties
were themselves Asians.
I just mentioned that
because it's gonna be helpful
in the next lecture when
we try to think about
what Russia is and how it
is or isn't like Ukraine.
Okay.
The first point I wanted to make today,
as we move from Rus' to Lithuania,
is again about language.
I want you to remember
that languages and peoples
are not exactly the same thing.
There's a modern fantasy which says that
there's one language,
and there's one people,
and it's all the same thing.
That often goes under the
heading of nationalism,
or ethnic nationalism, or ethnicity,
but languages are there
for you, and you can move
in and out of languages,
especially when you are young.
Hey, multilingual guys, stop
making jokes, stop whispering.
They're all like, we
speak a lot of languages.
I'm sure your TFs have been like that.
They've probably been like,
what languages do you guys speak?
Right, have they done that in section?
They have in fact done that in section.
I'm not surprised.
Okay, but actually, you know, I mean,
for Wiktor and for Maksimas,
the language that they're teaching you in
is a language that
they've moved into, right?
It's not their language of birth.
It's a language that they've moved into.
And the capacity for of humans to do this
is very important in politics,
especially in non-modern politics.
So when we're talking about this fellow,
Volodymyr or Vladimir, or
Valdemar, as his Scandinavian was,
we're talking about the fellow
who converted to Christianity
and in some sense began
the whole statehood project
that we're concerned with.
He's a Scandinavian prince, right?
He's from Scandinavia, his
family's from Scandinavia.
His successors even will
still be Scandinavian princes.
And his name is Waldemar.
And then he had, but there
are these nice Slavic
versions of his name.
Today we say Volodymyr and Vladimir,
but those names in turn seem
to come from Bulgaria, right?
So there's a Bulgarian Vladimir.
So is he a Scandinavian prince?
Is he a Bulgarian prince?
And this gets us thinking
in the right directions,
because he's not any one thing, right?
The way to come to power,
and very often the way
to stay in power, again,
especially in the earlier periods,
is to be more than one thing,
to speak more than one language.
So if we think about Valdemar,
or Vladimir, or Volodymyr,
we're right to think about the Vikings,
but we're also right to
think about the Bulgarians,
and we're right to think
about the Byzantines.
When he converted the
Christianity, he took another name,
which is Basil, that was
his baptismal name, Basil.
It's notable that he didn't
make that his main name,
that he stated his main
name remained Volodymyr.
So people come into languages.
Languages are there, you
can move through them,
you can do things with them.
So when I was in Ukraine the last time,
which is a couple of weeks ago,
I was speaking to someone
who was called Volodymyr.
And you know, that Volodymyr Zelenskyy,
he's also someone who's
coming into a language, right?
Ukrainian was not his best language
when he was elected president of Ukraine.
But now of course it's
his public language.
And just even I can
tell that his Ukrainian
is much better now than it
was a couple of years ago.
And when I spoke to his
wife, Elena Zelenskyy,
she's also, we spoke Ukrainian.
And I think I made her feel
good because my Ukrainian
was just, you know, I made mistakes.
And I think that put her at ease.
But you know it's cute, I made mistakes.
Mistakes are cute.
An old guy making mistakes is cute.
It's like one of the
many advantages we have.
But she was coming into a language,
like I was coming into a language, right?
Ukrainian is not, I was
speaking Ukrainian with her.
Ukrainian is not my
language of birth, right?
It's like fourth or fifth best language.
I was coming into a
language in a different way
she's coming into a language, right?
You can come into languages.
Another related theme is that Volodymyr,
Waldemar, is coming into a religion.
So a conversion is a
kind of sideways move.
You don't really stop being a pagan
when you become a Christian,
it's not that your whole past disappears,
it's that you're moving into
something which already exists
and brings with it certain features.
In this case, it brings with it priests,
it brings with it another
language, of church Slavonic.
It brings with it a tradition.
It brings with it a heritage,
because the moment that you
convert into Christianity,
you're inheriting the Bible,
and so hence the history of the Jews,
a very ancient history.
Like you're not putting yourself
into that timeline as well.
Because you're going into Greek,
you're also going into the tradition
of the ancient Mediterranean
world that way.
Suddenly you're in all of
these vertical traditions
that you weren't in before.
Okay, so we're gonna get
from, in this lecture,
we're gonna get from
Volodymyr to Yaroslav,
and then we're gonna get
from Yaroslav to Lithuania.
We're gonna end in Lithuania,
much the joy of our,
I'm counting them, three
Lithuanians in this group.
So the two great leaders of Rus',
if you just read like a
textbook about early Rus',
are going to be Volodymyr and Yaroslav.
And we have, so first we
have to get to Yaroslav.
It's complicated.
Okay, I mean, I could say
Volodymyr was Yaroslav's son,
and that would make it sound very simple,
but it's not really simple at all.
As you remember last time,
when Volodymyr took Ana,
the Byzantine princess Ana,
as his wife, he already had
about six others and, you know,
a harem of hundreds of women.
When he died, so his
relationship with his sons
was not straightforward.
When he died in 1015,
he had one of his sons,
and I tried to write all
these down this time.
He had one of his son's,
Sviatopolk, in prison, as one does,
he was making war against another
one of his sons, Yaroslav,
as one does.
So when Volodymyr dies,
Sviatopolk is freed.
Sviatopolk then arranges for, it seems,
the death of three of his brothers,
probably with the help
of Scandinavian allies.
Sviatopolk then goes to
war against Yaroslav.
Yaroslav initially wins,
with the help of some
Scandinavian allies, at
least that's according to
the tale of Evalynd, which
is an Icelandic saga,
which reminds you how this is all this,
this could all be Nordic
history, by the way.
We could be in a Nordic
history class at this point,
the history of Rus' at this point
fits in with the history of what's,
as Rus' is becoming a state,
so simultaneously are Norway
and Sweden becoming states.
It's a simultaneous, and it's
an intermingled, process.
So Sviatopolk is freed, but
then he's defeated by Yaroslav.
Then Sviatopolk goes to
Poland, and gets an army,
and brings it back.
He's married to a Polish princess.
He brings a Polish army back,
he defeats Yaroslav, Yaroslav goes east,
recruits an army of Pechenegs, comes back,
defeats Sviatopolk.
Seems that Yaroslav is now in charge,
but then yet another brother,
there were at least 10.
I'm sure there were many, many more,
but there are 10 that come down to us.
And then another brother
was called Mstislav,
which means something like
glory to revenge, beautifully.
Mstislav marches on Kyiv
and defeats Yaroslav.
As a result of this in the end,
Mstislav and Yaroslav rule
Kyiv together for a while.
Mstislav about a decade.
Mstislav dies in 1036, and
from 1036 Yaroslav rules alone.
Okay, I give you those details because
the colorful details from
all of the Scandinavian sagas
in the early Kyiv of sources
are very interesting,
but also because I want
you to see a problem,
which is the problem of succession,
how you get from one ruler to another,
how you keep a state going.
This is a key problem in political theory,
in political practice,
which you wanna mark.
Because even if you're just thinking about
contemporary politics,
like why, for example,
are things so chaotic in the
Russian Federation right now?
One of the first things
that you should try out is,
what's the succession principle?
How do they know who the
next ruler is going to be?
That's it.
So in early Rus', there was a
big problem with succession.
If you count it the way we're counting it,
from one ruler to another single ruler,
from Volodymyr to
Yaroslav, it took 21 years.
And along the way, at least
10 of the other children of
of Volodymyr were killed.
Okay, also I want you to
mark succession as an issue
because when we get into
other kinds of regimes
in a couple of weeks,
the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth,
the Russian empire,
succession is also going to be
a very important issue there.
This brings us to Yaroslav
and what is regarded
as the golden age of Kyivan Rus'.
His rule, which is the
1020s, 1030s, 1040s.
He rules by himself from
1036 until his death in 1054.
So Yaroslav is also a Scandinavian prince.
I wanna make sure this is clear.
The fact that he's a Scandinavian prince
doesn't mean that he's not
the prince of Rus', right?
But he is a Scandinavian prince.
He's in the saga of Harald Hardrada,
who is the king of Norway.
And he marries off one of his daughters
to that same king of Norway.
He himself is married to a
daughter of the king of Sweden.
As I've already said, some
of the sources about him
are Icelandic sagas.
And by the way, Iceland
sagas are the earliest
significant European literature.
They're quite extraordinary,
but they're also interesting
historical sources
because they record
events that are only about
one or 200 years before
when they were recorded,
and they're based on oral tradition.
So they're pretty good
comparatively speaking
to historical sources.
And, oh, he also married one of his,
So Yaroslav also married
one of his own daughters
to the king of Norway, right?
So we're very, here, connected
to the history of Scandinavia.
And it's inconceivable
that he didn't speak
whatever we wanna call
the Swedish language,
or whatever we wanna call it at that time.
He did marry another one of his daughters,
this is just something we have to know.
He did marry one of his other daughters
to the king of France,
which is a fun fact,
which every Ukrainian
needs for you to know.
So we're gonna make sure
that it's in this class.
That would be Yaroslav's favorite daughter
who was called Ana, who was
remembered as Anne of Kyiv.
Because from the point of view of Paris,
she was Anne of Kyiv.
She, in the middle of the 11th century,
she was the queen of France.
She was the one who
went to Paris and said,
compared to Kyiv, this is
kind of dingy and pathetic
and wanted to go back.
So now you know, that's Anne of Kyiv.
So Yaroslav is a Scandinavian prince,
but he is also an inheritor
of Byzantine Christianity
from his father.
And he is also the ruler of
a Slavic speaking population.
So it's like there's a triangle.
So on the Byzantine side
of the triangle, he builds,
or maybe he completes
the church of San Sophia,
which is the central cathedral in Kyiv,
which still exists.
It exists in a kind in a kind
of Baroque reconstruction,
but which still exists and was completed
somewhere around the 1030s.
And it was modeled on Hagiya
Sophia in Constantinople.
So the main cathedral
in Kyiv was modeled on
the main cathedral in Constantinople.
So he's balancing that.
With that church came
Greek speaking priests.
The first priests who came
to convert the population
were from Constantinople.
They spoke Greek.
And with these Greek priests,
and with the conversion
came a certain model of order,
which might seem
intuitive to a lot of you.
It seems so natural, perhaps because
it's now more or less hegemonic,
but it had to arrive at a certain point,
which is the days of the week.
The days of the week and the
idea that the day of rest
is the seventh day, Sunday.
Churches and churchyards
come with Christianity.
The idea that you bury your
dead, as I mentioned before,
rather than cremate
comes with Christianity.
That you bury them in a certain place,
a cemetery in a churchyard,
comes with Christianity.
So there's a civilizational package,
which comes with the Greek priests.
But interestingly, it is
Yaroslav who shifts over
from Greek priests to local,
Slavic speaking priests.
In the year 1051, he
manages to have appointed,
or appoints himself, as the
local head of the church,
the metropolitan, a man called Helarion,
who was a local Slav and not a Greek.
And somewhere around this time as well,
and this is crucial, the
language of the liturgy
gets changed from Greek
to old church Slavonic.
So in other words,
there's a big difference
between going to church
and hearing a language that
you can't understand at all,
to going to church and hearing a language
where you can understand
a little bit, right?
So that's basically the shift from Greek
to old church Slavonic.
Geek, from the point of view of Kyiv,
is a foreign language.
Very few people speak Greek.
They're mostly people who have
arrived from Constantinople
or Greek traders coming up and down
from the Black Sea coast,
as we've talked about,
it's basically a foreign language.
And in the whole history
of the Greek church,
the Orthodox church, the
Eastern church in Kyiv,
relatively few people learn Greek.
Some people do, but relatively few.
Basically very educated
churchmen learn Greek.
Old church Slavonic is a different story.
You'll remember where old
church Slavonic came from.
Old church Slavonic is invented
by Cyril and Methodius.
It has this journey down to Bulgaria,
and now it arrives in Kyiv.
And it has the huge advantage
that it is a Slavic language.
It is based on a Slavic language,
probably the Slavic language
that was spoken in Macedonia
by the mother of Cyril and Methodius.
But it's based in a Slavic language.
And therefore, if you're a native speaker
of a Slavic language, you
can figure out a lot of it.
So when I studied old,
I'm not a native speaker
of Slavic language, but I
studied old church Slavonic.
A lot of it was intuitive to
me, a thousand years later
and with the funny glycolytic alphabet,
but a lot of it was intuitive to me.
I could look at it and see a lot of it.
So it's not totally impenetrable and,
once you start with a Slavic language,
and this is very important,
you can then start to mess with it.
You can then take it as a
basis of a written language.
And then with time,
vernacular words will start
to make their way into the language.
What's the vernacular?
The vernacular is the language
as we actually speak it.
As we actually speak it.
And so Slavic words, as
people actually spoke them,
made their way into the written language,
thereby enriching it and changing it.
And this language, church Slavonic,
slowly becomes a written language,
which is serving not just the church,
but also the state.
And this is hugely important because,
if you're going to run a state
as distinct from a church,
it's good to have law.
It's good to have a language in which
you can record that law.
So old church Slavonic, in
the version that it's used
in the Kyivan state, is usually
called Chancery Slavonic.
Just to make this distinction.
Chancery Slavonic.
And this Chancery Slavonic is recorded in,
is the language of a very important text,
which seems to originate with Yaroslav,
and then continues after his
time for another century or so,
which is called the Ruska
Pravda, or the Russkaya Pravda,
which is a collection of laws.
So there's secular law now.
There's secular law.
Not just church custom and
church law, but secular law.
And what the law itself says
is itself very revealing.
So now the law becomes a
historical source for us.
We don't just have sagas,
we don't just have genealogies,
we don't just have, you know,
legends about Rus' written in Kyiv
a century after the events.
We have the law, which was
applied in its own time.
What we see in this law are at least two
very important developments.
Number one, you see that
the society has shifted
from the kind of society we
talked about in the beginning,
which is one where
people could be enslaved,
to one in which the chief
preoccupation of people
was agriculture, and
agriculture is being regulated.
So we now have a state which is based upon
people generating a
surplus in agriculture.
The classic model, which
we see over and over again,
beginning in Mesopotamia,
the classic model, where
you can have a city,
and you can have a state
with a capital in that city,
because you have rules about
how you collect a surplus
from the people who are
actually working the land.
Which may be a somewhat
exploitative system,
but it's a very different
system than raiding
and slave trading.
It's a very different system
than raiding and slave trading.
And it describes a
relationship between a ruler
and his people, as opposed
to a relationship between
people who are just passing
through and collecting things
or people that they're going to sell
somewhere further down the river.
So by the time the law is written down,
that transition has been achieved
and we're in a different kind of society.
Maybe even more fundamentally,
what you see in the Russkaya
Pravda, the Ruska Pravda,
is an attempt to make a transition
from a culture of personal revenge,
to a culture where disputes
are actually settled in courts.
So I'm sure all of you,
you know, in your lives,
depending upon where you're
from, have some familiarity,
at least from, I don't know, film,
with what I mean by personal revenge.
Where I do something to your clan
and therefore your clan has
to do something to my clan,
and this can go on indefinitely,
and it can be very costly
and destabilizing.
If you're trying to set up a state,
you don't want this clan and this clan
to have a feud indefinitely, right?
If there's a dispute, like
this clan has stolen this,
or this clan has burned
down that, or whatever,
you want that dispute to come to me,
you want the dispute to come to the court,
to the state, where it can be resolved.
And so one of the things
that Ruska Pravda lays down
is what the appropriate penalties are.
So there's a generic penalty
rather than personal feuds,
this is the kind of thing
that builds up a state.
But, I keep coming back to this,
but a weakness in the state
is that it didn't have
the legal structures to allow
it to perpetuate itself,
which one finds surprisingly
often is a problem with states.
It's actually, it's kind of
the magic of founding a state
is how, the German sociologist Max Weber
was also obsessed with this,
how you get from the
stage of founding a state
to the stage of continuing a state.
Where you might found
a state because of some
great achievement or because
of some charismatic leader,
but neither the achievement
nor the charisma lasts.
And so then how do you keep
the state actually going?
Maybe you found institutions,
these institutions sound pretty good,
but how do you make sure
that people continue
to believe in them without the achievement
and the charisma somehow backing them up?
In then you event, how can
you do it without a procedure?
So, in Kyiv, when we
talk about Kyivan Rus,
we're talking about a range
of lands, going to the east,
going to the north,
going a bit to the south
and west of Kyiv.
We're talking about not
just Kyiv and Ukraine today,
we're talking about what's now Belarus
and what's now a lot of European Russia.
All the way up to a bit to
the east of what's now Moscow.
And these various
districts were passed out
to the various sons in an
extremely confusing order,
which honestly no one has figured out.
And one suspects it changed
from generation to generation,
or sometimes that they
were just making it up.
And if we don't know it, I
think it's forgivable because
whatever the rules were, the brothers
were constantly fighting each other.
And if they were constantly
fighting each other,
it means that whatever the rules were,
maybe they were contested, or not clear,
or maybe not taken always seriously.
So the rulers in Kyiv passed
out the various districts
to their sons, and there was
an idea that a certain son
at some point would
become the ruler of Kyiv
and will be superior to all the others,
but that never panned out the way that
it was supposed to be.
So after Yaroslav's death in 1054,
we essentially have one long confusing
series of succession crises
until the Mongols come in 1241.
There are however, at
least one moment in here
which I want you to mark,
which is the rise of a
city called Vladimir,
not the person, the city.
And we're gonna call it
Vladimir and not Volodymyr
because this city is all the way out in
the far Eastern extreme of Rus',
a little bit to the east
of where Moscow now is.
I say now, because Moscow
didn't exist at the time.
Vladimir, the city, was
ruled in the 1160s, 1170s
by a man called Andrey Bogolyubsky,
who I think is on your list,
should be on your list.
And he attacked Kyiv, not once, but twice.
The first time he successfully sacked it.
The second time he was repulsed.
But the point is that Andrey Bogolyubsky
had the idea that he
was gonna make Vladimir
the most important city, the
successor of Kyiv, as it were.
He took an important
icon that was near Kyiv,
and he brought it to Vladimir.
He built a church in Vladimir,
which was meant to look
like St. Sophia in Kyiv.
So he had the idea that he would
be the most important ruler
and that his city would be
more important than Kyiv.
So this is Vladimir, and
Vladimir is in a district
which is called Suzdal.
The Mongols are going to come,
they're going to wipe out Vladimir,
they're gonna wipe out Suzdal,
they're gonna wipe out
basically everything
in that part of Rus.
But I want you to at
least mark that this idea
was already here in the 12th century,
that there could be a successor to Kyiv
that could somehow be better than Kyiv.
Okay.
When the Mongols do come,
and we'll talk more about
the Mongols and what they were up to,
but when the Mongols do come,
we see a partition of Rus,
which is very durable.
I'll just say a word about the Mongols
and what they were up to.
Just a word.
It is always the case that
from the point of view
of the people whose cities get sacked,
that the arriving people
are just marauders,
and chaotic and so on,
but it is almost always
the case that, in fact,
what is happening is that
those who are arriving
are trying to establish trade routes,
admittedly on terms favorable to them.
And you tend to get, I mean,
this is why we now have a
European Union to avoid this,
but the way you get terms favorable to you
is you sack the city.
And then you get terms favorable to you.
I mean, it's tough, but that's how it is.
So the Mongols, like
the Vikings before them,
were trying to establish
a long trade route,
the Vikings over sea,
the Mongols over land,
in which they would be
able to trade favorably
all the way down the line
at terms which are favorable to them.
At terms which are favorable to them.
And they had tremendous success with this
everywhere they went.
They were never really defeated.
In the early 1240s, they
destroy what remains
of Kyivan Rus'.
You understand that when
they destroy Kyivan Rus',
they're not destroying a unified state,
because there is no unified state.
There are a bunch of
districts with rivals.
When the princes of Rus'
go out to meet the Mongols
on the battlefield, they're literally
arguing amongst one another
on the way to the battlefield
about who is who, and
who gets to go first,
and who's the most important.
So that gives you a sense.
Even if they'd have been
in perfect formation,
had loved one another, they still would've
had their hats handed them
by the Mongols, however.
The Mongols were gonna win.
So after the Mongol invasion,
we get a kind of three part division
of the lands of old Rus,
which I'm gonna mark.
And then we're gonna talk about
the most important of these,
which is Lithuania.
So, far off to the west
you have a district
called Galicia-Volhynia.
And that district, Galicia-Volhynia,
is going to have a slightly
different trajectory
than the rest, because Galicia-Volhynia
is gonna be ruled by its
own princes for a while.
And then the Galician
part of Galicia-Volhynia
is gonna become part of Poland
in the mid 14th century.
So that Western part of Ukraine,
Galicia-Volhynia, is going to have
a somewhat different history.
That's part one.
Part two, so that's the extreme west,
part two is the extreme east
or the extreme Northeast.
Suzdal, the areas around what is gonna be
at some point, Moscow.
Moscow has still not come
into being, but I promise you,
at some point Moscow will be created.
The territories in Suzdal in the Northeast
are going to remain longer
under direct Mongol domination.
That's also a different political story.
The Mongols are gonna come
and they're gonna stay.
And they're gonna establish a durable form
of transactional politics with the
inheritors of Rus' princes
in the far Northeast.
And we'll pick up that story next time
when I talk about the
origins of the state,
which is based in Moscow,
the origins of Russia.
The third and the most
important trajectory
is the one we're going to follow today,
which is the grand Duchy of Lithuania.
Most of the territory of old Rus'
comes under the grand Duchy of Lithuania.
And not only that, one of
the reasons why I've spent
so much time talking about
this civilization is that,
interestingly, this civilizational package
associated with Yaroslav, the language,
the Chancery Slavonic, the law
all gets absorbed by Lithuania.
The Lithuanians take it over.
They appropriate it,
they make it their own
very comfortably.
And so in that sense, the
Kyivan civilization survives
in the written form of its law.
So it's sometimes it's
helpful to think of history
as having different speeds, or different
elements in history having
different kinds of durability.
So a language has a lot of durability.
It changes over time.
A particular civilizational
package, like law,
it doesn't last as long as a language,
but it can last much longer than a person.
So the fact that Yaroslav
got the law together
has meaning, which goes
well beyond his lifetime,
deep into the history of Lithuania.
Centuries later, when Lithuanians
are gonna be writing their grand statutes,
which starts in the 16th century,
when they write their
statutes, three of them,
they're gonna be using this
language, Chancery Slavonic.
In turn, it's gonna have more words
from their part of the world and so on,
but this civilizational
package long outlasts
the actual Kyivan Rus'.
So the last big thing we have to do,
we've gotten Volodymyr to Yaroslav,
Yaroslav to the end of Rus'.
Now we have to get to Lithuania.
What is Lithuania?
And how could Lithuania be so, I mean,
isn't Lithuania just this tiny country?
It's this tiny country
filled with Baltic speakers?
How can it?
It was the biggest country
in Europe, my friends.
in Europe at the time.
And it emerged, as
countries often emerged,
because of pressure from two directions.
The Lithuanian state consolidated,
because of pressure from the west,
in the form of Christianity.
Now a very aggressive, pointed pressure
in the form of crusades.
A few centuries earlier,
when we're talking about
the Franks, and Poland,
and Moravia, and so on,
that's a more gentle pressure.
You know, we want you to convert.
Perhaps you'll be a little
bit subordinate to us.
We're now in the 14th century
in the era of crusades,
and the Lithuanians
were subject to violent,
forcible conversion.
By that I mean, all the men were killed
and the women and children
were taken and baptized.
That's what the Teutonic Knights did.
So pressure from the west,
the Teutonic Knights had
wiped out the Prussians.
I realize there's still
a place called Prussia,
but the place called
Prussia today takes its name
from an earlier people who
spoke a Baltic language,
similar to Lithuanian.
These people were exterminated
by the Teutonic Knights.
They no longer existed.
And as that was happening,
the groups of Baltic speakers
that are called the Lithuanians
managed to consolidate a state.
So they were consolidating
because of pressure
from the west.
And also, as we'll get
to, they consolidated
because of what the
Mongols did in the south.
So faced with pressure from the west,
the Lithuanian state in
the early 14th century,
in the 13 hundreds, was able to move south
from its base around Vilnius
into what's now Belarus,
and deep into what's now Ukraine.
And so, as they were
pressed from the west,
they took advantage of
what the Mongols had done
in the east.
It might help, although, you know,
in the kind in a kind of Christian
dominated historiography,
this would never be put this way,
to think of the Teutonic
Knights and the Mongols
as arriving at about the
same time, which they did,
and their arrival at about the same time
creating the conditions
in which a Lithuania
could face a challenge and
respond to that challenge
by gathering up
territories from the south,
from Rus, and becoming the
biggest state in Europe,
which it was.
So what do we know about Lithuania?
The Lithuanians, so I talked
earlier about the math,
the math of slavery and paganism.
The Lithuanians were the
last holdouts in this.
They were the last major
pagan group in Europe.
They were the last ones who
were able not to be enslaved
more than they enslaved others.
They were using slave labor of
others in their countryside.
They raided Rus' for slaves,
they raided Poland for slaves,
they also raided their Baltic,
their pagan neighbors for slaves.
So long as they had pagan neighbors.
They brought in tens
of thousands of people
to work as slaves in their agriculture.
We know that they traded
timber, and furs, and grain,
and wax and honey for iron products.
We know that they turned
a corner in their own
agricultural planning in
the early 14th century
under their most important ruler,
who I may not have put down, Gediminas.
Is he there?
He's there?
Okay.
So under Gediminas, who
ruled from 1315 to 1343,
they started moving away from slavery
and towards colonization,
where they would accept
the rules of local,
they would kind of control
land rather than people.
So in a way it's the
same kind of transition
you see earlier in Rus', control
land, rather than people,
accept basically the rules
that already existed.
And then try to tax.
It's Gediminas who moves
into what is now Rus'.
What was their religion?
Very briefly about this,
we know a lot more about
it because their paganism
lasted for another four centuries.
And many people had contact
with them, many Christians,
many Muslims, many Jews
had contacts with them
over the centuries.
There were Christian churches
in Vilnius the whole time.
Why?
Because if you're a
tolerant, prosperous regime,
you need to have traders
coming from other places
and you have to make sure
they have churches, right?
And additionally, just to make
sure this is always clear,
this story is gonna end with
the Lithuanian rulers converting,
but the Lithuanian rulers are
always ruling over a country
which is majority Christian.
Because most of the people
who are in Lithuania
are in what is now Belarus, and then later
in what is now Ukraine, i.e.
they're Eastern Christians.
So the whole time this is a regime where
the rulers are pagans, and the
ruling families are pagans,
but most of the population
are actually Christians.
So when I talk about this religion,
this is the religion of the Baltic core,
which then spreads out and
tolerates Christianity.
They make no attempt at
converting the Christians at all.
So we know that the grand
duke was also the high priest.
We know that the priests
were priests of sacrifice,
as in the Slavic lands.
We know what some of the
most important gods were,
who were familiar figures already.
They had a version of Perun,
who was called Perknas.
In general, if you just add us to the end,
you'll get a Lithuanian word.
So like, okay, doesn't always work.
Doesn't always work.
But the Lithuanian version
of Perun was called Perknas.
Other important gods were
Andai, who was associated with water,
Teliavel, who was associated
with like a Hephaestus figure,
associated with the smithy.
But as with the Slavic paganism,
the gods were not separate.
This is much more animistic,
it's much more a religion
where everything is in some
sense animated by divinity.
So trees were venerated.
Specific groves of trees
regardless as important.
In specific groves of trees,
the dead would be burned as a sacrifice.
Specific springs and rivers
and rocks were also important.
The Lithuanians, like the
Slavs, also didn't have temples
until they made contact with Christians.
And then they began to build temples,
it appears, as a kind of
borrowing from the Christians.
We know that they divined
omens from the behavior of,
some of them still do, from the behavior
of horses and snakes.
We know that after
victories they sacrificed
a third of the spoils to the gods.
We know that horses were
of special significance.
That horse skulls were meant
to ward off evil spirits.
That two horses in front of a
house, on the gable of houses,
was meant to bring good fortune.
We know that if you were
important and you died,
you were buried with your
horse so that you would
have your horse in the next world.
And Lithuanians also thoughtfully did this
to important people who they
captured on the battlefield.
So for example, when
they were in battle with
the crusaders, and they
captured important knights,
they would thoughtfully
burn them to death,
fully armed, on horseback.
That's a mark of privilege.
A major Teutonic Knight
who, so the crusading wars
between the crusaders and Lithuanians
were unbelievably fierce on both sides,
and were recorded by
the crusaders that way.
The conflict between the
crusaders and the Lithuanians
actually makes it into English literature
right at the very beginning.
So if you've had like a high school course
in English literature, where
you were forced to read,
where you happily read
Chaucer, the Canterbury Tales,
you might remember that when
the knight is introduced
as a character in the prologue,
he's described this way.
A knight there was, and that a worthy man,
that from the time that he
first began to riding out,
he loved chivalry, truth and
honor, freedom and courtesy
above all nations in Prus,
Prussia, in Lithau had he reysed
and in Rus.
Lithau is Lithuania and
Rus' is, of course, Rus'.
So the Knight in this
English story from 1380,
from the 14th century, is a Crusader,
but he's a Crusader in
Northeastern Europe.
He's a Crusader in Lithuania.
And that word, he reysed,
that's the German word, reyse.
And reyse, in this particular
context, every year
the Teutonic Knights declared
that there was a reyse,
which meant that all of
the flower of chivalry,
all of the Knights from the
other Christian countries
were meant to come and join the crusade.
That's what they did.
They had the crusade was a
kind of seasonal adventure,
which was called a reyse.
So it's the Teutonic Knight
who are forcing Lithuania
to consolidate and who are
pushing Lithuania to the south.
The Teutonic Knights creep
their way across the Baltic sea
as Polish rulers invite
them to come and deal
with pagan problems or other problems.
Teutonic Knight come,
Teutonic Knights stay,
Teutonic Knights
establish their own state.
They rule Teutonic state
along the Baltic Sea.
They do this in defiance of
the Polish Kings who say,
or grand Dukes often who say,
we just wanted you to solve
this particular problem.
They also do it by exploiting a specific
feature of Western
Christianity, which is that
the Teutonic Knights play off between
the Holy Roman Emperor, we'll talk about
what this means later on,
but the Holy Roman Emperor,
the chief secular figure in the west,
the chief secular leader, and the Pope.
They manage to play off
between these two patrons
and essentially do what
they want and become
a power into themselves.
So these are armed monks.
They are crusaders.
They're men who isolate
themselves from the world
who are trained in the
spirit of sacrifice.
Their fellow monks find them intimidating.
Their basic program of Christian
conversion, as I mentioned,
is that you attack, you kill all the men,
you resettle your own
men, and that's baptism,
that's conversion.
Their major achievement
was the colonization
of the Baltic Basin, from
what's now in Northern Poland,
all the way up to what's now Estonia
where Germans had some
kind of significant social
and political presence for
the next 700 years until 1945
and the arrival of the red army.
So they begin something which
lasts in some form or another
for a very long time.
So it is their war.
We're now getting to the crux,
which I'm sure you already understand,
it is their war against
Lithuania which coincides with
and brings about the Lithuanian absorption
of the lands of Rus'.
They are fighting in the late 13th century
into the 14th century.
I'm gonna read you one long quotation
from the chronicler of
the Teutonic Knights,
Peter of Dusburg, just
because it gives you
the flavor of how they saw it.
The odd kind of respect
that the crusaders,
the Teutonic Knights,
had for the Lithuanians,
but also the fierceness of this.
This is from 1283.
He writes, 53 years had
flowed since the war began
on the Prussian nation,
and all the nations
in the said land, Prussia, had
been beaten and exterminated
so that not one survived which
did not humbly bow the neck
to the Holy Roman Church.
Okay, so that's Prussia, which is gone.
The afore said brethren
of the German house, us,
Teutonic Knights,
initiated the war against
this mighty people, most hard of neck
and well versed in war, which
is neighbor to land of Prussia
dwelling beyond the Nemunas
River in the land of Lithuania.
So that's how it looks
from the Teutonic Knight's
point of view.
The Lithuanian reaction is not,
we will never become Christian.
Lithuanian reaction seems to have been,
we will not become Christian this way.
We will not become Christian this way.
So in the late 13th century
and the early 14th century,
what you have is a kind of
geometry of four powers.
Where there's Poland,
there's Galicia-Volhynia,
there are the Knights,
and there is Lithuania,
and there is What's left of Rus',
which is no longer a political entity.
So what happens is that the Lithuanians,
facing this challenge, move
south in the early 14th century.
They attacked the city of Breast,
which is now in Belarus.
By 1323 it appears that they
have also controlled Kyiv.
But the crucial thing here is that,
although there seemed to have
been some armed engagements
in the beginning, the
Lithuanian rule Rus',
not just in a spirit of toleration,
but in the spirit of appropriation.
So they come to the great ruler,
they come to the princes
of Rus', and they say,
in their own language, we're
not gonna bring anything new
and we're not gonna change anything old.
How do they say it in their own language?
Because remember the
Lithuanian Grand Dukes
are ruling a country which
is already majority Slavic.
It's already majority Eastern Christian,
it's already majority Slavic,
it already controls some of
the lands that had been Rus',
which is Belarus.
So it is not as though
Christianity, or orthodoxy,
or even the language
is unfamiliar to them.
They know all of these things,
they know what Christians are, right?
They know all of this stuff.
So they say to the princes of Rus',
you don't have to change anything.
We're just gonna marry into your families,
you're gonna regard us as
the center of the state,
and you're gonna organize taxes for us.
And that's how it works.
And it seems to have worked very smoothly.
So this process then all
comes to a kind of crux
in the last part of the 14th century.
The Lithuanians are pressed from the west,
they have absorbed the lands to the south.
But the way that the
Lithuanians actually find a way
to defeat the Teutonic Knights finally
is by making an Alliance with the Poles.
And this is carried out by the
second Lithuanian Grand Duke,
whose name I really want you to remember
after Gediminas, which is Jogaila,
or as he's remembered by
the Poles, as Jagiello.
So, oh, sorry, I forgot
something very important.
The Lithuanian Grand Dukes,
they not only know all about this.
They know about Rus', they
know that Rus' existed.
They know that Rus' was
a very important state.
And so to their own
list of titles they add,
we are the rulers of Rus'.
So the Lithuanian grand Dukes add,
So from their point of view,
they have not just
inherited the territory.
They've inherited also the patrimony,
in the legal sense,
we are the rulers of
this thing called Rus'.
And, as I said before, in the
earlier part of this lecture,
they inherit the legal language
and they began to use it themselves.
And that's not such a
stretch, because remember,
they're used to using Slavic languages.
Slavic languages are nothing
new, nothing surprising.
It's good to have a written one.
Okay.
But the way that this
history reaches a climax
has to do with Poland.
Poland has a succession crisis.
The king of Poland is a 11,
12, maybe 13 year old girl.
It looks for a moment as
though she's gonna be married
to a Hapsburg.
If that had happened, the
whole history of our region
would've been very, very different.
But the Habsburg, who was called Wilhelm,
who's riding to claim his
Polish bride never makes it,
he's stopped by some Polish
Nobles along the way.
And instead this girl is
married to a much older man.
I mean, I'm afraid it's
a little scandalous.
He's like 40 years older than she is.
Though Lithuania's not scandalized.
So, Jogaila, what is her name by the way?
Jadvyga or Hedwig.
She has a very interesting past, too.
I mean, she has a fascinating past,
she's only just a very young girl,
but she's been raised
for interesting things.
But anyway, she turns out
to be the king of Poland.
Her name is Jadvyga or Hedwig.
She marries Jogaila.
And in that way, a whole bunch
of things happen at once.
The Lithuanians, the ruling
family convert to Christianity,
1385, 1386.
Slowly, the Lithuanian nobility,
which includes the old Rusia nobility,
will merge with the Polish nobility
and start to take up some of its norms,
which we'll talk about.
But most importantly, a new
state, a defacto new state,
it's a personal union.
It's a personal union between
Lithuanian Grand Dukes,
who will also be Polish Kings, is set up
and it will bump along
for the next 200 years.
So the Polish, the Lithuanian Grand Dukes
and the Polish Kings are
generally gonna be the same people
for quite a while now.
For a couple hundred years.
And what this means for these territories
is hugely important for Kyiv.
We're keeping our focus on Kyiv.
This means that Kyiv is
gonna be attached to Vilnius
and to Poland from roughly
1320 until roughly 1670.
For a very long period of time,
which we'll be dealing with
in the next several lectures.
It means that this, so
there's also gonna be this,
the Northeast, there's also
gonna be Galicia-Volhynia,
that most of Rus' is gonna be in this
Lithuanian Polish synthesis
for the next several centuries.
Where this all leads to is a famous battle
that all the Polish kids,
and actually all the students
from much of Eastern
Europe will know about,
which is the battle of Grunwald.
The famous battle of Grunwald
which is famous for Poles,
famous for Lithuanians.
It's the battle where decisively, in 1410,
it's the battle which is
so shocking to everyone,
which it's referred to
by both Hitler and Stalin
during the second world war,
it's still taught as fundamental.
It's the battle where the
Lithuanian Grand Duke,
who is now king of Poland,
and can now marshal an army
which includes people
from Rus' and Poland,
as well as Lithuania, where he decisively
defeats the Teutonic Knights.
And the reason why it's
remembered, or one of the reasons,
if you go to central park,
which you will, right?
You're in New Haven, you're
gonna go to central park, right?
It's not far away.
There's a statue of Jogaila,
Jagiello, holding two swords.
And one of them is his.
And the other one is the
one which was given to him
by the grand master of
the Teutonic Knights,
according to legend at least,
at the beginning of the
battle on the logic of,
you're going to need this.
And so that little bit of
like Teutonic arrogance
got remembered down the centuries.
And so the notion of
Jagiello going to battle
with the two swords, and
of course the Lithuanians,
the Poles, the Slavs
winning is something which
made a big mark in history.
Okay, we're gonna leave you there.
We're gonna pick up with
this Polish, Lithuanian,
Ruthenian synthesis next time around.
But we're also gonna try to
explain how we get to Russia.
(ethereal chime plays)